[Music]
hello everyone welcome to Fandango indie
movie Guide I'm Alicia Malone and this
week I have a bunch of smaller movies to
tell you about some that feel
particularly important to watch right
now so let's get into it let's start
with the salesman and this film you may
have heard about in the last few days
because it's directed by Asgar for hardy
now the movie just got nominated for a
Best Foreign Film Oscar but because of
the new ban on people from certain
countries coming to visit the US it
wasn't sure that Asghar would actually
be able to travel here to the US for the
ceremony and that is an absolute
disgrace and incredibly sad but just
recently as go put out a statement
saying that even if he was allowed to
come he actually wouldn't come at all
he's decided not to attend the Oscars at
all so a way that we can support him is
by seeing his movie and it is brilliant
well my name is William shuh-shuh-gah
masquerading as Boris Italy do or did
you human
[Music]
the salesman shows a marriage between a
man and a woman in Iran and it's a
revenge tale of sorts after the wife
gets brutally attacked inside their
apartment the husband goes out to try to
find who did it
it also shows the everyday life for
people living in Iran and the great art
scene that exists there both the husband
and wife the lead characters Ahmad and
Rana are participating in the local
theater version of The Death of a
Salesman the play by Arthur Miller and
Asgar himself is very inspired by
theatre plus he's just so good at
exploring humanity as he's shown in his
previous films the past and a separation
and the salesman is another great
example of showing audiences a part of
the world that they might not get to
experience themselves and also the real
human faces of the people who live there
right now the salesman is only playing
in limited theaters in LA but it will be
expanding soon so keep a watch for this
one write it down
see the salesman as soon as you can and
support as gopher Hardy the documentary
I am NOT your negro is equally important
to watch right now and extremely
powerful if any white man in the world
says give me liberty or give me death
the entire white world applauds when a
black man says exactly the same thing
he is judge of criminal and she did like
one and everything possible is done to
make an example of this bad so there
won't be any more like him this feels
more like a film essay rather than a
straight documentary it uses images and
archive clips and narration of author
James Baldwin's work just after the
deaths of his friends Medgar Evers
Malcolm X and Martin Luther King jr.
when James Baldwin died in 1987 he left
just 30 pages of this book but director
rau Peck has imagined what his completed
work might feel like you also get to see
Baldwin speak in old clips like his
address to Cambridge University where
his fierce intelligence is on full
display there are days when you wonder
what your role is in this country and
what your future is in it the parallels
between the civil rights movement of the
60s and the black lives matter movement
right now impossible to ignore and it's
really only by delving into the past
that we can hope to change the future so
please see I am NOT your negro if it's
playing near you it'll give you plenty
to think about and it's out in limited
theaters this weekend another film
speaking about race in America which is
out this week is called chapter and
verse and it's the directorial debut of
Jamal Joseph now he is an in
recive man he is a filmmaker he's an
author he is a film professor he's an
activist and he's a former member of the
Black Panthers and he actually went to
jail for his involvement with that
organization
chapter and verse is a very small
low-budget indie which tells a story of
an ex-con trying to live a straight and
narrow life in Harlem he comes across a
young boy who's starting to get into the
gang life and takes him under his wings
but of course it's not so easy to stay
straight when you're living in that
cycle of violence make recruits prove
day was lawyer there was family real
family don't make you jeopardize your
future not to me
the filmmaking is a bit rough but it
does feel very raw and authentic I think
the fact that Jamal bases it on his own
experiences and also the stories of his
close friends and family that does make
it feel very truthful chapter and verse
is out in New York this week it's out in
LA in Chicago the following week and
then more cities to follow another film
that I want to mention quickly if you're
in New York you have to try see this one
it's called the Lua this is a polish
mermaid musical which I saw at Fantastic
Fest and it is just as crazy as that
sounds it's about two mermaids who end
up being nightclub singers but they are
very savage
it's like hands Christian Andersen fairy
tale Meets
Jack dummy musical meets a Eurovision
contest makes gothic music
[Music]
it's dark and stylish and well worth a
watch right now it's only in New York at
the IFC Center but I'm sure it'll be
released everywhere else soon so I will
remind you when it comes out further but
remember the lure sounds where to my
accent the Laura
on Zod this week is used in Oregon this
stars Frank Langella as an old grumpy
sick man who decides to travel to Oregon
to euthanize himself and Billy Crudup is
his son-in-law who's trying to convince
him otherwise I'm going back to Oregon I
want to do it stop it's my birthday
honey I couldn't say what I want
go on honey would you pass the bread
please the pacing is a bit slow but
Frank Langella and the rest of the cast
are great I mean Frank could not be bad
if he tried youth in Oregon is out on
video on demand and before I go I want
to mention another film this is
everything Gigi gorgeous if your parents
don't get you if your friends think
you're weird
I love you and I want you to be exactly
who you want you to be it's a
documentary that I saw at Sundance and
it ended up being one of my favorites
it's told by master documentarian
two-time Oscar winner Barbara Kopple
and it tells the story of GG gorgeous
who is a transgender YouTube star it's
expertly put together and really
inspiring I teared up quite a lot
watching this film because I cannot
imagine what it must be like to not feel
like you are the gender that you were
born in and also how incredibly tough it
must be to navigate that road the thing
that makes it so inspiring is that Gigi
is completely herself and damn anyone
who doesn't agree with her and it is
always so great to see someone living an
authentic life this is everything Gigi
gorgeous is out in New York and LA this
weekend and then on YouTube read on
February 8th I was scared
but I was happy I was the real meat
having Gigi happy is way more important
than me having old Gregg
so just to recap my ultimate picks this
week would be the salesman I am NOT your
negro and this is everything new GG
gorgeous in theaters each of these films
speak about an issue that is very
important right now and each of these
films are well worth your time and money
I know it's tough when I talk about
these films and you can't actually see
them but just try to write them down
because hopefully at one point or
another you will get to I'm Alicia
Malone you can follow me on Twitter at
Alicia Malone and I'll see you next week